einer gigantischen kollision unserer
milchstraße sind forschen jetzt auf die
spur gekommen eine äußerst
geheimnisvolle kraken galaxie hat die
entwicklung unserer milchstraße
entscheidend geprägt ein internationales
forschungsteam hat das mit hilfe von
künstlicher intelligenz jetzt entdeckt
herausgekommen ist dabei eine absolute
premiere der erste vollständig
rekonstruierte stammbaum unserer heimat
galaxie alle infos zu den gewaltigen und
mysteriösen kollision in unserer
milchstraße bekommt ihr jetzt bei kriegs
thoms 1 in future hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende science videos
harmoniert den gehalt und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasste nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen ihr
durchmesser beträgt unglaubliche 100
tausend lichtjahre
sie setzt sich aus bis zu 200 milliarden
sternen zusammen und nicht zuletzt ist
sie auch unsere galaktische heimat die
milchstraße die galaxie also in der wir
leben dennoch an fachleute sie noch
längst nicht im detail verstanden und
viele fragen sind noch offen eine der
wohl größten herausforderungen der
astronomie den stammbaum unserer
milchstraße zu rekonstruieren wie ist
sie über die jahrmilliarden entstanden
und genau das ist jetzt einem
internationalen forschungsteam gelungen
mit dabei waren auch astronomen und
astronomen der universität heidelberg
klar ist schon seit längerer zeit dass
in der milchstraße vergangenheit
wirklich dramatische veränderung
stattgefunden haben müssen die neuen
ergebnisse aus heidelberg und den usa
aber offenbar eine bisher unbekannte
spektakuläre kollision mit einer
mysteriösen kraken galaxie und dieses
ereignis hat die milchstraße wohl
nachhaltig geprägt also wie spürt man
milliarden jahre danach eine kollision
auf astronomie teams konnten bereits in
verschiedenen modellen zeigen dass vor
allem das verschmelzen eine große rolle
bei der entwicklung von galaxien spielt
denn durch verschmelzungsprozesses
gelangen galaxien nach ansicht der
wissenschaft über milliarden von jahren
an ihrer haupt massen eine super
chaotische vergangenheit also die auch
unsere milchstraße durchlebt hat doch
wie genau sah diese aus wie genau können
wir uns die verschmelzung geschichte
unserer milchstraße vorstellen hat
unsere milchstraße über milliarden jahre
hinweg mehrere große galaxien geschluckt
und ist dadurch zu ihrer größe gewachsen
auf diese
lange ungeklärten fragen gibt es jetzt
erste antworten für das forschungsteam
um den heidelberger astronomen die
direkt grüßen und seinem britischen
kollegen joel pfeffer waren dafür vor
allem die sogenannten kugelsternhaufen
von großer bedeutung diese
kugelsternhaufen hatten die milchstraße
1 in einer großen anzahl umgeben
möglicherweise könnten es sogar tausende
gewesen sein doch dann stürzen sie
ineinander oder wurden von der
milchstraße verschluckt und aufgesogen
etwa 150 kugelsternhaufen kommen
heutzutage noch überall in der
milchstraße vor vor allem aber sind sie
im so genannten galaktischen halos noch
zu finden
dieser umhüllt quasi unsere milchstraße
wie eine runde kugel charakteristisch
für kugelsternhaufen darin ist die
wirklich wohl stern dichte und dass sich
die sterne im inneren des zentrums
extrem verdichten hier lassen sich nicht
mal mit den leistungsstärksten
teleskopen überhaupt einzelne sterne
ausmachen im kugelsternhaufen ist die
sternen dichte im durchschnitt übrigens
achtung 20.000 mal höher als bei uns
hier in der umgebung dazu der astronom
die direkt größen von der universität
heidelberg viele von ihnen stammen aus
kleineren galaxien die einst zu unserer
heimat galaxie verschmolzen sind andere
der haufen entstanden wurde
möglicherweise auch innerhalb der
milchstraße ein wirklich spannendes fun
fact dabei die sterne die dieses ganze
chaos überlebt haben sind nicht nur
älter als jedes vor ziel auf der erde
sondern auch deutlich älter also seine
fachleute gehen davon aus dass ihr
ursprung tatsächlich zurück reicht bis
an die anfangstage des universums selbst
die analyse der kugelsternhaufen brachte
das internationale forschungsteam bei
vielen der bislang ungeklärten
forschungsfragen weiter spannend waren
dabei vor allem die chemische
zusammensetzung das alter und die
orbital bewegung der kugelsternhaufen
diese ergebnisse mussten dann mit den
eigenschaften der vorläufer galaxien
zusammengebracht werden in denen sie
sich einst gebildet hatten
denn sie behalten viele der
charakteristischen merkmale aus ihrer
mutter galaxie und sind so leicht
zuzuordnen auch wenn die kollision mehr
als zehn milliarden jahre her ist eine
super komplexe und spannende aufgabe
denn wenn zwei galaxien miteinander
verschmelzen bürgern deren
kugelsternhaufen quasi einfach
durcheinander
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
waren bislang daran verzweifelt denn das
gestimmt davon welche haufen in der
vergangenheit mal
gemeinsam eine eigene galaxie gebildet
hatten gestaltete sich bislang als fast
unmöglich bis dann konnten aufgrund
dessen lediglich vier frühere galaxien
identifiziert und bestimmt werden die
mit der milchstraße verschmolzen sind
dazu der astronomen die direkt größen
die größte herausforderung war dass die
bahn bewegungen der kugelsternhaufen
beim verschmelzungsprozess in extrem
chaotischer art und weise verändert
werden um diese komplexität zu
überwinden haben wir ein neuronales
netzwerk entwickelt und mit hilfe
unserer ehe mosaik simulation trainiert
wir waren erstaunt wie genau die
künstliche intelligenz die
verschmelzungsprozesses der von uns
simulierten galaxien nur anhand ihrer
kugelsternhaufen rekonstruieren konnte
also nochmal zusammengefasst zu dem was
sie vorher gesagt habe
die eigenschaften der kugelsternhaufen
den ehemaligen galaxien in denen sie
sich befanden zuzuordnen ist leicht aber
nur für künstliche intelligenz wir
menschen sind da quasi zu nicht in der
lage die künstliche intelligenz half den
fachleuten außerdem dabei die
charakteristika und eigenschaften der
kugelsternhaufen in der milchstraße
näher zu analysieren so konnten
beispielsweise die stellaren massen und
zudem sogar auch die verschmelzung
zeiten der vorläufer galaxien bestimmt
werden und das mit einer hohen präzision
und die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler kamen zu einem weiteren
spektakulären ergebnis denn bei ihrer
analyse entdeckten sie eine kollision
zwischen der milchstraße und einer
bislang unbekannten galaxie eine äußerst
mysteriöse galaxien diese galaxie die
von der fachwelt jetzt als krank
bezeichnet wird muss vor elf milliarden
jahren mit unserer milchstraße
kollidiert sein ein super prägendes
ereignis für unsere heimatgalaxie wie
der wissenschaftler niedrig größen sagt
die kollision mit der kranken galaxie
muss das bedeutendste ereignis gewesen
sein dass die milchstraße je erlebt hat
daher muss diese kollision das aussehen
unserer heimat galaxie nachhaltig
verändert haben der astronom bezieht
sich dabei auf die tatsache dass die
milchstraße vor elf milliarden jahren
viermal weniger masse besessen hat als
heutzutage eine enorm große und
spektakuläre kollision auf die das
internationale forschungsteam da nun
gestoßen ist deutlich enormer noch
einmal als der zusammenstoß mit der
geier enceladus galaxie vor etwa neun
milliarden jahren
dieses ereignis hatten fachleute bislang
als das größte kollision zeit
beurteilt ein trugschluss wie die
aktuelle studie aus heidelberg nun
zeitgleich aber die aktuelle studie
schaffte es zum ersten mal einen
vollständigen familienstammbaum unserer
heimatgalaxie zu erstellen das
internationale forschungsteam geht den
neuen ergebnissen zufolge davon aus dass
sich die milchstraße im laufe ihrer
geschichte mit insgesamt fünf galaxien
vereinigt hat in ihnen waren wurden mehr
als 100 millionen sterne versammelt doch
nicht nur das hinzu kommen etwa zehn
weitere galaxien die mindestens zehn
millionen sterne in sich trugen
die massereichsten vorläufer galaxien
sind aktuellen analyse wohl vor sechs
bis elf milliarden jahren mit der
milchstraße kollidiert doch wie können
die überreste dieser vorläufer galaxien
aufgespürt werden
genau dazu könnten die ergebnisse der
heidelberger studie beitragen davon sind
die beteiligten forschenden überzeugt
dazu den drittgrößten weil mehr als fünf
von ihnen ist dies bereits gelungen mit
dem bestehenden und mit künftigen
teleskopen sollte es möglich sein sie
alle zu finden denn wenn wir in die
vergangenheit gucken was wir immer tun
wenn wir milliarden lichtjahre weit ins
universum sehen dann können wir diese
galaxien vor der kollision mit unserer
milchstraße entdeckt
doch nicht nur der blick in die
vergangenheit der milchstraße unserer
heimatgalaxie super spannend auch einen
blick in die zukunft lohnt sich und hier
gleich vorweg das motto fressen und
gefressenwerden wird sich hier wohl
nicht ändern und so gehen
forschungsteams fest davon aus dass die
milchstraße nicht ewig existieren wird
in etwa vier milliarden jahren wird sie
nämlich mit der andromeda-galaxie ihren
nachbarn zusammenstoßen gerade kommen
sich die beiden galaxien immer näher und
das ziemlich schnell mit etwa 400.000
kilometer pro stunde rasen sich
aufeinander zu und die kollision hat
bereits begonnen
dazu gibt es in den nächsten tag an
extra video dafür einfach klick zum
abonnieren das geht hier und hier geht
es weiter mit das zentrum unserer
galaxie entzündet sich anklicken
anschauen und eben krieg substanzen
future abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran